back at your bullpen um did someone clap
when they heard I got a PhD I know hi so
I'm thrilled to be here and looking
around the audience that you know it's
hard not to think of bringing coals to
Newcastle but I appreciate you coming
and I'm going to tell you today a bit
about what we've been doing in the lab
some recent progress in autism genetics
and really I wanted to spend some time
talking with you about how we've been
thinking about sort of what the next
steps are now that we've had some
success in gene discovery and autism
what some of the conceptual challenges
are and how we're trying to approach
that in the lab so quickly some
disclosures I don't make any money from
any of this so there's really nothing
that that is terribly pertinent autism
spectrum disorders so autism
neurodevelopmental disorder appears in
the first months of life is generally
fairly stable across life and is
characterized by fundamental appearance
of social communication as well
competitive and restrictive behaviors
that's the new diagnostic formulation in
the DSM the core deficit of social
pyramids has lasted throughout from the
earliest descriptions of autism and well
many of you may think that this is a
really big wake think about diagnosing a
human disorder and it is and and you
know we suffer this across psychiatry
where we make diagnoses simply by sort
of observing and listening behavior and
coming up with syndromic diagnosis in
fact i think is important to know that
if you take two psychiatrists and you
put them in the room with someone who
has a classical autism in my office so
when you're anything that I said this is
better okay so if you put put two people
two psychiatrists in a room with someone
who has classical autism they may not be
able to agree on anything but they will
both diagnose the child with autism so
the inter-rater reliability is very high
and what that suggests is that whatever
else is true we're able to recognize a
set of fundamental symptoms that we can
all agree is sort of profound social
disability we've known for many many
years the genes play a major role as a
general proposition
almost all of the studies and now
they're about a dozen of the genetics of
autism show very high concordance of
monozygotic twins and the dizygotic
concordance rate has creeped up over the
years particularly as the diagnosis of
autism has broadened to include really
all kinds of levels of severity of
social communication problems but the
the difference between monozygotic and
dizygotic concordance rates so twin
studies and Family Studies all show that
the lion's share of the risk for autism
is carried in genetics one of the
reasons I went back to do a PhD was
because of this third bullet I was
working on units as when I was training
as a child psychiatrist and see kids who
are profoundly disabled we know very
little at that time we knew almost
nothing about the underlying
pathophysiological mechanisms and it's
very frustrating in the absence of that
that we really don't have any effective
somatic treatments for the core deficits
that we see in autism we can help a bit
with behavior we can use behavioral
approaches to make life somewhat better
but we really have nothing that gets at
the core limitations particularly in the
social domain so the idea that really
started my lab and continues to drive
the lab is that a lack of insight into
molecular cellular and circuit level
mechanisms has profoundly limited our
ability to think about how we develop
new and more effective treatments and
then really a minimalist notion that
genes are one way in to solve that
problem so it will get you to the
molecular level so my lab as a genetics
lab we have not been terribly interested
in things like population risk or how to
explain all of autism we've really been
focused on identifying genes of large
effect that we can then use as a to pull
on the thread to see if we can
understand biology so this was sort of
I've been showing some version this
slide for now 20 years and and this was
the initial idea that we would find
particularly a rare mutation rare
mutations in humans have a tendency to
have large effects or larger effects so
we would find a rare mutation reliably
that we would know that that was related
to the human phenotype and then we would
pull on this thread by studying Express
and function by moving to model systems
then ultimately by elaborating pathways
identifying treatment targets and moving
forward and I'm going to come back about
half way through the truck to tell you
why after 20 years of looking at this
diagram I realize it was profoundly
wrong and but I'll get there okay so
autism genetics very briefly I gave you
two slides on the history of autism
genetics before talking about some of
the more recent work from our lab so one
thing that I want to point out is that
there's been tremendous progress in
human genetics and in all areas of
complex common human disorders they
progress in the genetics of autism has
been somewhat distinctive so when you
talk to most people about what's
happened in the last few years in
genetics there's really been this really
explosion of understanding of the
contribution of common alleles alleles
that are present a significant portion
of the population and their contribution
to the risk for things like
schizophrenia bipolar disorder diabetes
and and a host of other phenotypes there
are hundreds of phenotypes now where
state of the art studies have
demonstrated the common variation plays
a significant role and are sufficiently
powered now to be able to identify
specific alleles these ten common
alleles tend to have relatively small
effects particularly in
neurodevelopmental disorders but the in
with regard to autism unlike
schizophrenia or many other disorders so
far the search for common alleles has
not been productive there's tremendous
evidence that common alleles will play a
role in autism but at present the sample
sizes are I've just been too small for
us to be able yet to leverage I believe
this is going to change which in the
next day last week could change okay so
it changed two weeks ago but as a
general proposition I think it's fair to
say and even I'm sure Ben would agree
that 5,000 was not quite enough and that
and not surprisingly as we get to larger
and larger samples were going to be able
to identify that but in contrast to some
other conditions in fact the search for
rare variation has consistently been a
thread throughout the history of autism
genetics has been extremely productive
so this started really many decades ago
with the cloning of the fragile site on
the X chromosome that then led
the discovery the fragile x mental
retardation protein it's been clear for
as long as people have had their kind of
eyes open to it that there's an
increased rate of autism within kids who
have fragile X and it also turns out to
be the case than in many a single gene
or monogenic forms of intellectual
disability that you see increased rates
of autism studying those things has
turned out as I'll show you to be highly
productive not just to characterize
those quote-unquote rare forms of autism
but actually appear to be at least
providing evidence that there are
important points for understanding more
broadly autism in its more typical form
what we see day in and day out in the
clinic the first success is in what you
call idiopathic autism a more typical
autism this is autism where there is not
an intellectual associated intellectual
disability syndrome or identifiable dis
morphology but again just the kids we
would typically see in clinic really
began around 2003 Thomas bergeron's lab
in Paris was studying rare families
looking at regions of the genome where
they could see that there were deletions
under the light microscope and then
sequencing those regions and found
mutations in in neural again for X that
then led to the identification of neural
again 3 these are synaptic adhesion
molecules that had mutations now I think
we have real confidence that they're
associated with autism and then we're a
handful of others using often similar
kinds of approaches finding regions of
the genome that were grossly disrupted
than identifying the gene that was
responsible including shank 3 and Rex
and one contact associated protein 2 is
somewhat different but was found in in
consegna sped agrees it's a recessive
form of autism so what these pointed to
relatively early on just after the turn
of the millennium were that rare
recessive and de novo mutations actually
both neural again for x and rex and one
more initially identified and actually
shank three as well we're identified as
new mutation so the observation and the
offspring not and the parents led to
focusing on those regions and then
looking for the gene within them so it
really actually almost all of
the sort of recent progress can be
traced back to the Bergeron lab in 2003
with these very initial observations
about these kinds of mutations and and
really important but there was a very
long period where really this gene
discovery was sporadic at best so my lab
was trying to do the same thing that
Thomas's lab was doing we started in
1997 and you know after many years of
looking and trying to find these kinds
of rare families we were really
struggling and actually contributed a
bit to contact an associated protein too
but apart from that we're almost a
decade of what felt like wandering in
the dark so the the shift I think in the
field certainly with regard to rare
mutations came at about two thousand
seven two thousand six late two thousand
six in which because of the advances in
genomic technologies it was possible to
screen the entire genome for small
submicroscopic deletions and
duplications of material called copy
number variation and when you could do
that in kids who had quote unquote
idiopathic autism so typical autism it
became clear very quickly that you
didn't need to look in that many in
order to identify that children with
autism particularly if they were the
only affected child in the family were
much more likely to have a new de novo
copy number variation the submicroscopic
delusions or duplications compared to
controls now that was you know the
initial observation was really important
several things about it so one you there
was a type of mutation that we could
detect and where we didn't need huge
numbers in order to be able to see a
significant difference and that
suggested that the effect side effect
size was going to be large so the first
studies were less than a couple hundred
people and you could still see that
there was a difference between cases and
controls but the second really important
observation was that these were not did
not appear to be randomly distributed
around the genome it did not appear that
there was a chromosomal breakage problem
in kids with autism because when we
looked we began to see almost
immediately after that first officer
vision by jackman and the Jonathan
savate in my quiggles lab is a series of
papers here in which it showed that
there were certain
the genome in which these were lining up
and in particular the first that was
identified was on chromosome 16 16 p 1
1.2 and what this suggested was two
things again one is that the effect
sizes were large and the second was that
you could begin to use the observation
of seeing the same mutation or very
similar mutation in the same spot in the
genome to begin to narrow in on genetic
loci and ultimately genes contributing
to autism so um most of what of my lab
has done since that point has been a
consequence of a major investment from
the Simons Foundation they created
something called the Simon's simplex
collection driven by those early
observations that new de novo mutation
was contributing to autism and they put
together what at the time was quite
unique but it was a sample that was
designed to enrich for de novo mutation
and you can look here and see so this is
just to parents blue is unaffected red
is affected and all of the families had
this structure they had unaffected
parents that were evaluated both
categorically by saying do they have
autism or not and also by dimensional
measures of social ability etcetera so
to do the best job that we possibly
could to say that these guys were
unaffected and then that we were very
fastidious about characterizing a child
that was affected and in about eighty
percent of the Simon's families there
was also at least one unaffected sibling
and when you think about this this is
it's a it's a pedigree structure that's
designed or it looks like you know that
it's been hit by lightning and when you
think about de novo mutation right the
idea would be that if it looked like
there was just this something arising
spontaneously in the family that that
would enrich for the the observation of
de novo mutations so it laid out this
really beautiful and simple experiment
and the simple experiment is that
whatever tool you had available to look
through the genome you could compare the
DNA of the parents to the offspring
anything that was present in the
offspring and not present and the
parents was at least possibly a de novo
mutation and then you just have to go
and confirm whether that's the case de
novo mutation is sufficiently rare that
that was not a particularly difficult
thing to do you don't
see that many observations so generally
I'm fond of saying that this is really
my style because all you have to do in
most pedigrees is count to 10 1 or 0 so
you compare the parents DNA the child's
DNA and then the the beautiful thing
about the Simon sample again was that
I'm the way that it was designed then we
could compare the rate of those events
within us within families of the
affected to the unaffected child and
this was tremendously important because
one of the big compounds in genetic
studies is not appropriately matching
between cases and controls so you have
to do a lot of gymnastics in order to
make sure that you're not looking at
differences that are just a consequence
of ancestry and not a consequence of the
disorder that you're ascertaining for
but when you're working within a family
whatever the ancestry is of these
parents it's going to be randomly
distributed to their offspring and so
you can use that essentially that 20 out
or normalize the influence of ancestry
and asking whether or not there's an
increased rate of de novo mutation in
cases versus controls so the first study
that we did and was published in 2011
we've just followed up with the entire
sample so the first study was a thousand
families that was about five times
larger than the study of sabato
Jacquemont this is Stefan Sanders who's
now an assistant professor at our place
out at UCSF who you'll see his picture
many times brilliant young assistant
professor who's led this work over now
almost seven years in lab so the first
study was about a thousand families we
just published a neuron of paper that I
now characterize the entire Simon's
sample which is nearly 3,000 families
and what you're looking at is the rate
of de novo mutation these are
duplications in blue deletions in red in
in pro bands versus their siblings and
and this is it's divided into the
subsets in the first sample then the new
samples and then the combined sample
just to show that we're getting
consistent results across the separate
parts of the Simon's simplex collection
and if you look all the way over on the
right this is the number of de novo CNVs
in cases versus controls and this is the
number of genes within CNVs so we knew
from our first study that if
CMV is war genic if they contain genes
that that appear to be more of a risk
event than those CNVs that did not carry
genes and so pretty much all the shows
is no matter how you cut it for de novo
events copy number variations you see in
excess in cases versus controls and this
is just showing that that signal is not
present when you look at transmitted
events so all of the signal that we're
able to derive in order to discover G
doesn't mean that there's no risk here
they're just many more transmitted
events than there are de novo events and
so the signal in noise ratio with regard
to de novo mutation is much more
beneficial to searching for novel genes
now so we've got two things de novo seen
bees are more common in pro bends and
siblings I'm just going to make a quick
point here that everywhere we look we
find that de novo cmbs particularly
those that contain genes are more common
and girls than boys and I'm going to
come back to that in a moment now I told
you that and from the first observations
even in a couple hundred people were
followed very quickly by seeing that the
cmbs were not randomly distributed and
very early on we worked with a Bernie
Devlin and Catherine Raider back in
2009-2010 to think about how we could
come up with a rigorous statistical
framework in order to be sure that when
we were looking at a de novo event that
it was truly related to autism because
de novo events also happen controls
they're at a greater rate in cases but
you see them in controls as well and
frankly all that we did is we were able
to leverage the fact that these were de
novo events and and what I mean by that
is that you know a de novo event is
happening at most at once a generation
typically the kind that we're looking at
and so instead of simply counting the
number of observations in cases versus
controls once we understood enough about
the characteristics of the mutation we
could ask how likely is it that a de
novo mutation will happen in the same
spot in the genome more than once and
when you use that you get an awful lot
of statistical power because the target
is big and the number of shots that you
have at it is small and so actually a
relatively small number certainly
compared to looking at common variation
a small
number of recurrent events gives you
high confidence that you're looking at
it at an Associated copy number variants
and this is from 2015 summarizing all of
the copy number variants that have now
been identified that reach our threshold
for genome-wide significance and we use
two different approaches to do that the
only thing I'll point out here is that
we've taken to using a false discovery
rate as an alternative to a p-value
particularly as I move on to talk about
a de novo point mutations so the idea is
just to give you a sense that there are
a number of low side we can actually
predict that they're going to be many
more than this but these clearly after
several years of study are a handful
that are carrying very large risks and
that are reliably associated with autism
I'll talk more about that in a minute
now there many other events are seen in
the clinic and and there are lots of
ways to think about whether or not
they're likely to be pathological this
is the list of those from all of the
large-scale studies that allowed us to
look at de novo variants that reached
our statistical threshold so a
relatively constrained view of the copy
number variation landscape in asd what I
want to do is focus actually on just one
region and and this is from our first
study in 2011 we replicated the finding
that 16 p11 was associated with autism
and then we identified a new locus 7q
11.23 and we found that duplications in
that region led to two classic autism
and looked hard at the phenotype to see
whether there's anything unusual about
it and couldn't find anything I'm just
going to show you a brief video here of
a kid with autism for those of you who
don't are not familiar with the with the
clinical phenomena there's no sound here
and there one of the reasons I use is
that you don't really need sound in
order to be able to identify kid with
autism so I think you probably saw at
the beginning flapping which is
repetitive stereotyped behaviors very
characteristic of autism and again you
don't need to know this child has
essentially no useful language that that
the sense about how the child is
relating to the adults in the room
that's a
father on the right and examine or on
the left this is you know one version of
profound impairment and social
communication this for a 13 year old boy
the way that he exists in the room I
think for most people it's it's
relatively apparent that this is not
sort of typical social interaction so
this is a region 17 11.23 there are 23
genes in that region what I want to show
you is is what happens when the
identical region of chromosome 7 is
deleted and this does have sound so all
I want you to pay attention to is the
social relatedness of every kid in the
room and kids love to make friends but
not like these that's my favorite line
chat at you buddy so um this is Williams
syndrome and it's been known for a long
time that deletions on chromosome 7 q
where we found this duplication lead to
autism lead to Williams and Williams has
a very reliable behavioral phenotype and
you're looking at it very very social a
tremendous interest in in reciprocal
social interaction and a variety of
other really interesting things that I
won't get into but the reason that I
show that is that and i'm going to show
you other data as well so when we found
these CNVs they are associated as our
other de novo mutations with decrements
in IQ versus what you would expect from
parental IQ which is typically the way
that you would predict where a child
should be okay and so we definitely see
a shift in IQ down when we find these de
novo mutations which have led some
people to question whether or not what
we're finding is just general failure of
brain function that leads to
intellectual disability along with
cognate with social disability and one
of the reasons I like to show this is
that
well those things often can go together
both of what you saw classical autism
and kids with with Williams syndrome in
fact when we looked across our kids with
7q there was no difference in overall IQ
but you can still see that as a
consequence of these mutations that they
can manifest in profound differences in
social reciprocity and I think what that
suggests is that well both may be
affected I think it's important to keep
in mind that these still have the
potential we believe to identify
critical aspects of neural systems
underlying social behavior as well as
just general cognitive abilities now we
thought this was really cool in 2011 and
even in 2015 to be able to identify
specific regions with high confidence
that lead to autism and would be the
start of that process of pulling on the
thread but really not the ideal
experiment because the ideal experiment
would be to get to single genes as
opposed to groups of 20 or more genes as
many of these cmds contain and so this
became possible this is the just to
remind you of how dramatic the progress
has been in the the declining cost of
sequencing the genome and so now genomes
are 2015 depending upon where you buy
them are somewhere in the neighborhood
of two thousand dollars and this opened
up the possibility of doing exactly the
same experiment that I described with
regard to copy number variation now we
could do with regard first to the exome
so the coding portion of the genome and
we did exactly the same thing so you
know again count 21 is and and what
happened is that actually bends up there
somewhere there you are so pretty much
everyone landed in the same spot at the
same time which is that we all found
that if you looked at de novo mutations
that were damaging particularly those
that resulted at least putative ly in a
loss of function that you saw the same
kind of over representation that we saw
with regard to copy number variation and
we could use basically the same approach
to defining the statistics of this to
use the recurrence of de novo mutation
at in a single gene as a way to increase
statistical power so with relatively
small
samples and relatively few observations
we could be confident that we were
looking at a SD jeans so mark Daly's lab
with been in the lead my lab with Stefan
in the lead and Mike wigglers lab also
brian or oak was formerly a grad student
of mine I like to take credit for him
sometimes who is in M&I closed lab so
you know I have to say that I know there
probably are not many psychiatric
geneticists in the audience but just
this slide is remarkable to a
psychiatric geneticists because for so
long the field was characterized by
everyone contradicting each other it was
like oh we got a common allele and then
two weeks later would be like no and
then everyone would argue about why a
non replication was really a replication
and so it really is it it it explains
some of my kind of recently found
optimism in the field that now I'm able
to stand up and show that really
regardless of which lab you're in that
we're ending up with with essentially
identical answers just like the list of
CNVs that i showed you now i can show
you a list this is from Stefan's paper
that was just published and what we've
done is there were actually two major
papers just before this from one from
the Simon simplex collection the other
from the autism sequencing consortium
and we took all that data and put it
together and then we took the exome data
that have been previously published and
and used a statistical framework that
allowed us to combine evidence from copy
number variation and from exome data in
order to identify autism genes and so
this again I told you that we we like to
use a false discovery rate and here the
false discovery rate is less than point
zero one for some of these a CHD eight
sen to a it's much less than point zero
one and but we also let people kind of
take a look at additional genes that
we're identifying that are you know are
showing evidence I wouldn't say that
it's definitive evidence but you know
what this is it allows people to kind of
pick what they want to do if you want to
make an animal model would make strongly
suggest that you stay to the left here
is it the left or your right I don't
know and but if you're doing you know
thinking about doing a systems analysis
or computational stuff you know you
might want to be including genes that
may not have rock-solid evidence but
still
greater than ninety percent chance of
being related to autism so they're just
a couple other things that I wanted to
point out and this gets back to this
question about what is it that we're
finding so we find these de novo
mutations we found them in the structure
of the DNA and we find them in the
sequence of the DNA when they're
damaging and and again this question has
come up and this is just a different
line of evidence that suggests that
while there may be overlap with
intellectual disability it is not the
same thing as intellectual disability so
that's the top panel and then the bottom
panel I just want to talk about for a
moment because I think we now have the
power to begin to really ask the
question whether or not the large CNVs
are going to resolve down to a single
kind of smoking gun or whether it's more
likely that there are multiple genes
within those regions that are
contributing so what this is showing is
nonverbal IQ and these are the
percentage of pro bands with the de novo
loss-of-function mutation or cnv and uh
and let's see do know the loss computers
don't see an be so what a number like
you number like you trying to figure out
what we did here sorry no I got that I
just trying I'm looking at what this is
so I percent of probam with a de novo
loss of function janome OC and v 0 this
just has the cutoff of an FDR point one
this is Annie de novo variant and this
is a de novo variant with with an FDR so
in that group and and and what we show
is that regardless of IQ well you can
definitely increase the yield of de novo
mutation by looking in kids who have
lower IQ and this reflects what we saw
as well just in the early CMV papers is
that you still see an
over-representation of de novo mutation
across the IQ spectrum and again this is
really just because i think it's when
we're thinking about whether or not we
can leverage these to understand
something fundamental about the
phenotype that i'm interested in since a
core feature of that is social
disability it would not be a good thing
if we were finding genes that were
primarily responsible just for
intellectual disability with kind of an
epiphenomenon being poor social function
all right so some additional
observations from these studies so the
vast majority of de novo
and v's were from father from the first
papers that I pointed out in 2012 from
Mark's lab and our lab and Brian and and
Evan eichler's lab so these increased
with paternal age a definite phenomena
everyone has replicated this it is a
small effect relative to the putative
increase in the rate of autism in the
population so it gets nowhere near
explaining an increase overall
population risk but you definitely see
that the eighty to ninety percent of the
de novo mutations are point mutations
not CNVs but point mutations are coming
from fathers we can predict based on
knowing the mutation rate and how
quickly we're seeing double and triple
and quadruple hits that there will be
somewhere between four hundred and a
thousand genes arrow bars are pretty
large but the scale is more important
it's not going to be ten unlikely to be
10,000 somewhere in this neighborhood we
can also just do kind of a
seat-of-the-pants look at what the
function the overt function are the
genes that we've identified and and
really half of the initial genes that we
pulled out are at least within databases
are identified either as chromatin
modifiers or being involved in synaptic
function and so you know we do more
sophisticated analysis you know using
gene ontology etc this holds up and then
as I said the fragile X mental
retardation protein it's it to me and
fascinating that this thing that we
found 60 years ago and it took a while
for people to really appreciate there
were increased rates of autism in this
population but it's really one of the
strongest signals if you're a target of
fragile X mental retardation protein you
are much more likely to be an autism
risk gene and there are other proteins
where there's convergence but this is
really the one of the strongest repeated
findings we can predict that de novo
point mutations will account depending
upon who you are either for fifteen to
twenty percent of individuals presenting
to clinic and thirty five percent of
females or about ten percent of
individuals presenting to clinic and
twenty percent of females the difference
really is that our our calculation here
in Sanders at all was only around
loss-of-function mutations and these
guys are predicting what ultimately a
signal will be
from missense mutations we're a smaller
subset of them are also carrying risk
for autism as I said there's an IQ shift
to the left but the excess of de novo
mutation cuts across the IQ spectrum
I've already told you as a greater
mutation burden and girls and then
there's a nice paper Nature Genetics
that shows that three percent of the
population risk in autism is
attributable to de novo mutation and
many people get stumped by this because
I keep telling we talked about fifteen
to twenty percent of individuals but
only three percent of the risk and I
just want to remind you that when we
think about risk if you think about a
normal distribution of risk we think
that most of the if this is risk for
autism that most of what's under this
curve is a consequence of common
variation but most of that will not have
someone reach a threshold for diagnosis
so what we're looking at with the de
novo mutation are very likely and their
multiple lines of evidence suggesting
this are that these are just larger hits
and even though they account only for
about three percent of the total
population they account for a
disproportionate amount of the tail end
of the distribution of people who come
into the clinic complaining of autism
symptoms now we also have know that this
is not really this is not Mendelian risk
these are not quote unquote single gene
versions of autism and and the reason
that we have a good idea about that is
that if you have a first child who has a
de novo mutation the chances that the
second child will have autism if the
first child has autism of Nova mutation
the second child will not be back at the
population base rate so if the de novo
mutation were typically carrying all of
the risk you would expect that a second
child without the de novo mutation would
have a three percent risk of autism but
in fact it's significantly increased
it's not as high as families in which a
child is diagnosed with autism who
doesn't have a de novo mutation but what
it suggests is that these de novo
mutations are acting on a common variant
background and that that risk is
accumulating in families with the de
novo mutation pushing one over the
threshold alright so the view from here
we have some wonderful opportunities as
I said the source of my great optimism
we have coding mutations we have loss of
function heterozygous mutations that are
falling in regions of the genome that we
can read
interpret and they have very large
effects so we can estimate in general
that the group that was all the way on
the right that has an FDR of less than
point 01 as a group have odds ratios in
the neighborhood of 20 so these are big
biological hits they're rare in the
population but they but they they carry
a lot of weight biologically and for
someone like me who's interested in
using genes as a starting point for
understanding biology that's a really
nice thing um and now we have a
systematic approach to gene discovery in
autism so that we have a really good
idea that if we keep feeding trios into
our sequencers and and thinking about
you leveraging the recurrence of de novo
mutation we're going to be able to
continue to discover genes our challenge
is so these are rare mutations the rare
mutations everyone always asked me well
what's the relationship of genotype to
phenotype when you see a CHD eight or an
scn to a mutation do you know anything
interesting about the phenotype we have
very few observations in any of these
genes so unlike schizophrenia where if
you have a sample of people with
schizophrenia almost any sample that you
have you could do something like a
polygenic risk score and begin to
stratify any sample if we bring people
into the you know to an imaging study
only a small fraction of them will carry
a de novo point mutation would be
unlikely that we would see more than one
in that sample the second is it clearly
it's genetically highly heterogeneous
and then this is really a big one which
is that all the genes that we're finding
pretty much all the genes are either you
know kind of notoriously pleiotropic or
they once you get into delving into
their function you find that they're
also pleiotropic that they will have
multiple different functions
particularly across development and so
the notion as I pointed out in my
diagram of simply identifying the gene
and then assigning some specific
function to that gene as a way to
understand something tractable about the
pathophysiology of autism is made quite
difficult essentially when you pull on
the thread for most genes you run into
either all of synaptic function or all
of biology then we have the problem that
there's tremendous anatomic and cellular
diversity in human brain about which we
know relatively little and then because
interested in development I have to add
that then there's a dynamic nature to
brain development and all of these
things complicate this as i said the
diagram that i realized after 15 years
when i finally started identifying genes
that it was embarrassing because i'm a
child psychiatrist and if you look at
this development is nowhere around so
this is a really good diagram if you're
studying hypertension but it may not be
a really good diagram if you're trying
to understand a developmental brain
disorder so we really turn you know to
try to figure out so what is it that we
can do then to begin to use these
genetic clues in a tractable way and and
a lot of this came about as a
consequence of conversations I have with
a close still close collaborator from
Yale and the knots esten and some were
prompted by actually one conversation
with Steve Waxman so we discovered Sen
to a the first couple mutations that
suggested that was an autism gene steve
was down the hall he is mr. sodium dr.
sodium channel so ran down the hall to
talk to him was so excited at an autism
gene and he was just absolutely
unimpressed and I couldn't figure out
why until he said if you can't tell me
what cell type at what point in
development to model this it's useless
because I guarantee you that whatever
cell type I put it in if i put in
purkinje cell i'm going to get a
different electrophysiological signature
for your mutation than if i put it in a
cortical neuron and if i do it early in
development we may cede arrangements in
neuronal migration if i do it later in
development you'll see abnormalities in
and in electrophysiological properties
and so we sat down and tried to begin to
think about whether or not we could
answer the question when and where do
you want to model these genes um so
instead of thinking about mutations as
targets we decided because no nod was
starting the brain span project with
several other people and mapping out the
molecular landscape or the
transcriptional landscape of developing
quote unquote normal human brain these
are post-mortem samples but without
gross abnormalities and so we began to
think about whether or not we could ask
the question about convergence not about
what these genes were doing but from a
developmental perspective asking when
were they doing them so
we took multiple different mutations in
genes that had overtly different
function was there a point in space and
time in development in which at least
the gene expression profile suggested
that they were working together sub
serving some sort of shared function and
from my standpoint as a child
psychiatrist and and and thinking about
again a developmental context is that it
seems at least as likely to me that
there are multiple ways to mess up the
system and that because we see a
reliable phenotype because we can all
agree what autism is and it involves
fundamental impairments in social
interaction um that again it might be
more important when and where that
happens then the then the specific
nature or something convergent about
exactly what is going wrong so the way
that we did this was led by Jeremy
Wolsey who now is also an assistant
professor at all place at the time is a
graduate student in the lab and the idea
was to leverage the brain span data
which nanad helped create and this is a
transcriptional map of 15 different
periods sort of arbitrarily defined
across development that go from
embryonic stage 2 late adulthood and
these are post-mortem human brains and
then to do it across 15 different
regions of brain um again in order to be
able to begin to give you something like
an unbiased map of the transcriptional
landscape this is gross you know we know
that there's tremendous cellular
diversity and specificity in human brain
and these are chunks of tissue but
they're chunks of tissue that are
reasonably defined anatomically at least
as a first cut in brain so we we did
it's like you know Reese's peanut butter
cups so he had chocolate and we had
peanut butter so our peanut butter was
the highest confidence autism genes so
at the time this was in 2012 we decided
that we would focus on those genes where
we really felt absolutely certain that
they were carrying autism risk and used
them to build transcriptional networks
so that we would try to minimize the
noise from getting too far away from
what we really understood of the
genetics so we built co-expression
networks around each of these genes for
each of these periods and in each of
these brain regions so we had a matrix
of 16
brain region and time with coexpression
networks that were seeded by these high
confidence asd genes so then we asked
two questions really the primary
question that we asked was if you do
that and then you take another set of
genes where there's a high probability
that their autism genes do you begin to
see those showing up in the same network
because we region that reason that not
only were these genes if they were
coexpressed that they were biologically
related but if that biological process
was related to autism you ought to see
additional autism risk genes being
pulled into the networks so we asked
about the enrichment of probable ASD
genes in these networks that we built
around the high confidence asd genes and
again these are done across short
periods of development usually two to
three periods and so we're looking both
at temporal as well as spatial data in
these co-expression networks so then we
asked do these enrich and I'll show you
a heat map that that actually surprised
us so these are all the brain regions
that are then collapsed it really
doesn't matter how you do this you get
the same answer but these are collapse
based on higher clustering of the
transcription data and and what we found
was that this is mid fetal development
so this is birth here this is about 14
to 20 weeks um that and this is the
negative log p value that we found
enrichment in these networks for these
probable autism genes in prefrontal
cortex and then we found this signal
disappeared when we correct it
appropriately for multiple comparisons
and this survived and this is the medial
dorsal nucleus of the thalamus and the
cerebellum we were not as confident
about this finding because the
underlying data from brain spam was was
pretty sparse but this data was actually
quite rich and it points to a overall
strategy in this which is that we were
not trying to be sensitive and we
certainly were not trying to find sort
of a unifying theory of autism we're
trying to be as specific as possible to
see whether or not any region of the
brain I showed increased coexpression a
greater than we would expect by chance
and enrichment for autism genes and we
found Bo
in this period three to six so as I said
these are 10 to 24 weeks this is in
cerebellum we focus predominantly on
this and then the interesting thing is
once you have this what you've got is a
network a co-expression network that
shows enrichment for additional autism
jeans and you can begin to ask questions
about what are the properties of that
network so we could go back and just
take a look at markers for different
layers of the cortex and ask whether
this autism enrich network was also
enriched for specific cellular markers
and what we found was that the autism in
rich network was really enrich for deep
layer cortical glutamatergic neurons now
that I say it's an autism network but I
really want to be clear that it is an
autism Network defined by nine high
confidence genes that have lots of
function mutations in them so again this
is not trying to get a global picture
but since what we were starting out to
do is to say where should you look at a
mutation or more importantly if you had
mutations in three or four different
genes is there a way to use a convergent
approach to try to examine phenotype and
this to us would suggest that at least
one reasonable strategy to move forward
be to take a look at the high risk genes
that we've identified here that have
loss of function mutations and to model
them in developing cortical
glutamatergic neurons this is just a
cartoon of what the strategy was but
what I like about this is that in the
end so these are all the high confidence
genes and just gets back to this idea
that you know we have actin binding
proteins we have chromatin modifiers we
have you know a sodium channel and the
initial axon segment and and so this
really supported the notion that at
least one way to think about convergence
or systems biological approach to autism
would be to focus on developmental
trajectory and spatial temporal
distribution of risk and not focus as
much necessarily on it on signaling
pathways or overt function of any
individual gene this just shows that
there were multiple papers that came
either a coincident or just after our
paper they all show somewhat different
results they all start with somewhat
different groups of autism genes but I
think
you know one of the things that you can
begin to identify is that even with kind
of this gross data which are chunks of
brain and getting transcriptomic data
from that that you do begin to see that
there's a you know that there's a strong
convergence around the notion that we're
looking at cortical and early to mid mid
fetal development as a convergent point
for developmental risk and autism so
obviously one of what we would love to
do and have been now pursuing for the
last several years has been to try to
increase the resolution the analysis and
so all of the work that's going on to
create cell-specific transcriptomic
transcription profiles profiles of gene
regulation to really parse the brain in
a way that makes more sense in the
developing human brain and then also to
do that in model systems that our
hypothesis would be that the better
resolution we have in those kinds of
foundational resources the more likely
we would be to be able to really begin
to identify where to model where to look
for phenotype with some of these
mutations but what I want to turn to in
the last three or four minutes is just
to talk about where we're headed now
which is to begin to do whole genome
sequencing and our focus on whole genome
sequencing actually is exactly the same
as what I've described so whole genome
sequencing now allows us to look across
the entire non-coding genome or almost
all of it in addition to coding exons
and what we're really our group is
really interested in here is not so much
identifying additional genes we believe
that the power to identify additional
genes using this method will be less
than looking for de novo point mutations
in the coding regions of the genome just
everything we know suggest that if it's
a non-coding it's likely to have more
subtle effects than a loss-of-function
mutation and they highly conserved
protein and and and it's much easier for
us to interpret loss-of-function
mutations in coding but looking at the
exome if you're interested in spatial
temporal distribution of risk you get
nothing from Exim unless you can like do
elaborate studies of splice variation
and know how specific that is and then
know that your mutation is in one splice
variant versus another basically
practically you get no spatial and
temporal
data from an exome study but you can get
spatial and temporal data from studying
the non-coding genome and the reason is
that the regulatory architecture of the
genome can be much more tightly related
to cell type and brain region than
individual genes and so this is just a
cartoon suggesting the strategy that as
we begin to get traction on single cell
analysis um that when and and we can use
chip seek and dnase hypersensitivity in
order to begin to identify regulatory
elements and that those regulatory
elements are likely to be distributed
based on the cells that we're looking at
and the time and development when we're
looking at them and so what we're hoping
then is that this is an orthogonal
approach when we find mutations that we
find likely damaging mutations either
near genes that we've already identified
as having autism risk or clustering
around genes that we have not yet
identified that that can begin to tell
us where the risk is specifically
relevant to autism or likely to be
specific to autism as opposed to being
more global and then you know once we
have an idea about if there's a cell
type a particular point in time at least
we have some traction less on the
temporal dimension but certainly to
certain extent on the cell type by then
modeling and demonstrating whether or
not in fact the mutation is having an
impact so again you could start to do
this simply by looking at all of our
high confidence genes and looking for de
novo mutations around them and seeing
whether or not those begin to tell you
when and where it looks like mutations
are more relevant for autism and this is
just a slide summarizing that but since
I'm down to less than five minutes it's
just basically what I said but what I
want to show you is and this is really
really preliminary data that should be
taken as really really preliminary data
more as sort of a conceptual example as
opposed to really anything that you
would want to you know hang your hat on
but this is just showing that when we
correct for father's age we see no
difference in de novo mutations in the
non-coding region in autism versus in
siblings this is a Simon simplex set
which has been so profitable looking at
at
fected vs. unaffected but and this is
only 40 families and we're now in the
midst actually working with mark mark
daily and David Goldstein and
dramatically expanding this sample to
about 1300 families from the Simon's
simplex collection but just as kind of
an initial look when we look at
enhancers in particular and and then
what we did is we decided well what's
what would be the equivalent of like a
loss-of-function mutation an enhancer
that you could interpret and we just
thought well if you lose more than one
base pair that's probably worse than
losing one base pair so we looked at in
dells and enhancers and we can begin to
see even in 40 people that we see in
over-representation and in dells but we
only see it in in frontal cortex so the
idea right behind this analysis is that
we can look at mutation burden when we
look across the entire brain we may get
no signal but we may be able to use the
distribution of non-coding variation to
begin to parse when and where in brain
that there's an over-representation
alright so I hope you get the sense that
if you didn't know before you walked in
the room that there's been a profound
change in the genetics of autism that we
have traction on on some very important
developmental processes as well as kind
of the centrality of F MRP as an autism
risk gene we have several points of
convergence both functionally but we
also can think about convergence in a
spatial temporal way really just to set
the stage for the next set of
experiments the the creation of
foundational data that's just all
happening now is going to help we
believe resolve some of these
developmental findings by giving us a
better underlying map of those
dimensions and then we hope that that
really does begin in the not-too-distant
future to begin to tell us about what
when and where this is relevant and sort
of what the level of analysis needs to
be in order to get traction I think what
our strategy now has evolved to is
really moving away from the idea that
genetic mutations are going to be
targets related a syrup utica
development really to the fact that
they're going to give us clues about
developmental trajectory that that's
going to lead us to an understanding of
the underlying circuitry and then that
maybe the level that we need to get to
in order to be able to intervene
for patients and families and I'm just
going to end with a very optimistic note
really it's hard for someone who's been
in this field for 20 years to not
believe that this is the very first
stages of a major revolution in
understanding and treating childhood
psychiatric disorders so thank you very
much for your attention